yestiny finally came out yesterday we
had a bunch of GameSpot editors playing
it all day long something stupid like 15
hours here are three of them
Mary Kish wrecked a Chris waters hey
let's talk about first impressions it's
been a day
the review in progress on gate went up
on GameSpot today Kevin oh it's full
review is gonna be up later in the week
and this video review going up in a
couple of minutes as well but first of
all you guys is first impressions on it
and you play for a lot of time yesterday
yeah like each of you play for bit six
hours each alright nine-nine yeah thanks
Amy
okay thanks as well alright first
impressions right at the gate uh it
feels to me like destiny would be like
the hottest thing like so revolutionary
if I hadn't played if you know I didn't
know about its predecessors if I hadn't
played a bunch of Halo a bunch of
Borderlands a bunch of other
first-person shooters that was someone
who was like hey next-gen consoles seems
kind of cool what could I play on it Oh
shooters neat Destiny's one I see on the
buses it's cool let me play it like it
does a lot of stuff in like a very
polished a very well executed way but it
doesn't really get exciting for I feel
like for me until well into the game
yeah felt like hours into it because of
difficulty or just because all these a
part of it yeah no difficulty is
definitely a part like when we were
taking on and like towards the end we
were playing a very you know very hard
it was like a few levels enemies are a
few levels above our level we had to use
all our weapons we had to use our
abilities we had to be nimble we had to
support each other every what does it
say yeah like all that stuff started
clicking but before that wasn't really
happening so I think I feel like that
run up you know for me is it's like you
know it's kinda like going through the
motions the gear you get is not exciting
the the enemies you're facing are kind
of pushovers but if you're you know if
this is your first kind of experience in
this kind of game then I think that
run-up is good like I think people need
that so I feel like that's sort of where
they've how they've calibrated it and
Mary you play a lot of Borderlands right
yeah I loved Borderlands especially you
know ii won the crap out of it i
remember when you were playing yesterday
one of the things that you were giving
out about which i actually haven't even
considered is that it drops off the
bosses and stuff yeah blame they are you
know this is something like i constantly
Herot to borderlands because that's the
easiest comparison to make for me and
you know what makes it fun are the
people that you play with you have so
much fun playing with your friends and
you enjoy taking down these massive
bosses and losing you honestly have a
really good time trying again changing
up your weapons and trying a different
tactic but the reward in Borderlands is
always the figure the boss the better
the drop that sometimes even important
cuz there are randomized right sometimes
you don't get a good drop and it pisses
you because you work really hard for
that drop I want to see a good gun more
often than not though you do get
rewarded for that
not so much in destiny you pretty much
don't get drops from the bosses besides
like ammo you'd find chests sometimes
after the jobs but you got to be really
quick because after you like achieve
your goal you get like what 25 seconds
like run around and like see any crates
and no you get those within a story
mission yeah yes mission kind of close
it sounds like Michigan's back no you
can come back later and find the same
chests and that happened to me I got it
I open the chest like right as my doggy
schimminger like faded black and I did
it didn't get my piece and it really
sucks but like you can go back to it but
I would have loved to see more drops to
me that is a part of what makes that
style of game so enjoyable is I want to
see the next gun I have a sweet gun I
love it now I want the next one you get
gun crazy that's kind of what's so
interesting about that I find myself to
be gun crazy this is the this is the
footage they'll play back on the news
when you eventually she was such a nice
girl okay you actually completed the
main story stuff this morning right yeah
I finished it this morning
I still like one other story quests that
I have to do but I guess that was like
the actual like class level story
no no spoilers but no spoilers what did
you what did you think of it have a
Brock don't buy the world um I mean
doesn't wrap off leaving it it's it's
kind of like a movie right it doesn't
really ever end right so movies and Eric
okay fine we know those movies with
villages and whatnot you know they
always find a way to loop it back around
and like okay there's more to explore
and I for me personally going through
the motions of playing the whole
like up to now I would say the beginning
part like Chris said it's kind of just
like this kind of tedious a little bit
maybe because we play beta 2 I don't
know um
but once I started getting like further
along and even for yourself it's like
some of the some of the missions get a
bit harder you guys have to do more
tactical stuff together
and in terms of the guns I don't want to
spoil too much but you know there's it
looks like there's possible more inch
possibly more interesting types of
weapons in the future that we haven't
really seen yet hopefully I'm not
blowing that out of proportion but for
me I have like one new thing that is
like totally kind of not totally but
it's different from what we've seen from
that first part of it like an open til
yesterday so and that made me excited
so I'm also curious about all the raids
the endgame stuff like because that's
when the game starts right yeah they
kept saying that right it like starts at
level 20 what level were you but it's on
me finished I was 17 no I was right
about the tip to 17 so I was 16 was
about 18 we weren't that far off then we
don't doing the the stream yesterday
anyone play on their own at any stage
you did idea that's night how did you
find playing on your own um so it's
interesting because it's easier
obviously there's less mobs there's less
for you to deal with okay however you're
punished more if you die there's no one
to resurrect you know you start all over
that happened to me a couple times a day
where I just got a little too greedy so
a little bit too overzealous and it's
just like I'm gonna punch this guy I was
like nope he punched me and I died and I
was like forty percent through that
mission is that cocky yeah there's no
one else to resurrect him yeah we bumps
you back to the sort of beginning of
degree and it's like you know
resurrecting limited yeah right that's
tough that sort of kicks in when you
know you're entering us an action
stretch can we talk about one thing we
haven't really touched on so far
this game looks so people and going to
different planets and like different
environments and just like exploring it
was something we actually didn't end up
taking a lot of time to do on the stream
yesterday because we were kind of like
go go go see this stuff show me stuff
get level up level up like taking the
time to just kind of like look at sky
boxes look at you know look at that and
look at the corridors you're going
through to get to the boss and like
today I was going through one that was
like his caves with these glowing
crystals and like this flowing
shimmering water
this strange color and then I got closer
to where the boss was in there because
these piles of bones like thousands of
bones holy crap what the hell like
thousands of bones oh my god like it's
and it's it's a gorgeous game so that is
I think that's one thing that nobody
argues with right I mean there's all
these people saying it's sucks or it's
amazing it's the best game one thing
that people really don't argue with is
it is a beautiful game they've done a
tremendous job with the environment it's
with the weather it sprinkles down or
they like like this this at least hits
the bar the next game should be hitting
like I don't find this to be yeah next
thing is I don't find this to be any
more beautiful than something like in
from the second Sun the one thing that
you're stuck I for me is regardless of
the fact that it does look good and the
skyboxes and all that stuff look great
the actual worlds the places themselves
I found kind of solace and Kevin said as
much in his a in his earlier progress
yeah like these places feel like
instances rather than actual places
which I found a little bit disappointing
hmm I feel like there you know I think
there's a way to play a game and there's
a way for a game to encourage you to
play that allows you to sort of sit down
in the world a little bit you know so
for example this what we're seeing now
is on Venus doing up doing patrol so
you're just you just pick up a mission
and that you're in a certain area you
know doing a bunch of stuff fighting a
bunch of enemies so it encouraged you to
stay in that given area and like do
different things here and there like
focus on different stuff and you can
take some time to sort of look around a
little bit more that said the story the
story is a little scant yeah you know I
think and the storytelling like it feels
to me like the mythology is there and
there's like really interesting pieces
but they don't they don't really come
alive and tie together through the
storytelling as I've experienced it
myself thus far yeah yeah I think I
don't know a Bungie to me like I was
never too wrapped up in the halo mythos
either but at least those games never
really took themselves too seriously
I feel like this is maybe like diving
into it Smith us a bit more but it's
just kind of lame I don't know like the
story stuff I don't think is
particularly interesting whatsoever yeah
I think there's something to be said
about maybe the story kind of really
reaching right because
have these heavy sci-fi moments where
they're they're saying something really
important like oh you know this this
looks like it could be really bad but
it's it's not saying it in a sarcastic
tone they're being genuine but you won't
most want to laugh because those are
like very kitschy sci-fi things that you
see they're cliche but you forgive games
in that sense from it like dinkle
himself is like that's really
interesting Carrie he's a fantastic
actor he's quite a very serious role and
does he play that role the way that we
want him to have a lot of times I feel
like that role itself is like a
problematic role because he's saying
very stereotyped things and he has to
say them very genuinely very serious he
is exposition boss like the only reason
that guy is there is basically to them
to take a replacement for menu text yes
like that's all he's doing
that's right but it's really hard for a
serious actor to take that role and to
do it the way did I feel like he got
kind of a bad he got bad I mean it
seemed like a road to me it just seems
like that's you know yeah just come here
and why get dinkle then Peter Dinklage
you've already to fire five you've
already completed it is this something
you think you're gonna keep playing
because I do you want people to be
playing yeah so it seems like beating
the story is just like step one so to
speak
I'm curious right now just to see you
know is something gonna unlock at 20 you
know or are we just gonna have to walk
around wander around and see the race I
want to see what the raids are I want to
see what these materials I'm picking up
two crafts yet or what's known as a
level I don't know I don't know where
there's like there's like strike
missions which you have to run with a
fireteam of up to three people and those
are on every planet but the stuff that
Bundys mentioned about six player raids
is sort of the phrase they've used I
haven't been able to see those I haven't
seen any of those well so to touch on
that point it's like Jeremy has gone
back to the sewers like an old Russia
where you know we seen the skulls the
question mark eyes and he's like 15 16
and there's still question mark skulls
for him yeah so maybe it's like one of
those like there's there's areas little
pockets like icy areas where there kind
of looks like black smoke almost like
the
is a way to get through there but
they're not letting you go through there
now I'm pretty sure those are enemy
closets you think so yeah okay he was
full of the monster Klub that's the
darkness I mean they're always talking
about the darkness I think like
literally that that's their like how do
we just put a closet in this cave here
the dark it's great you get Jackie a
staccato to turn up and start killing
Italian mobsters yeah great problem all
right